the government building in Donetsk is a
fortress and firmly in the hands of the
self-declared People's Republic of
Donetsk behind the barricades there are
stones and incendiary devices but we're
not allowed to film them on our way into
the building we are searched repeatedly
there's oh yes they are very strict on
security we checked journalists in
particular very closely you have to
understand the troublemakers keep trying
to get in here disguised as journalists
not just troublemakers but even spies
yelling they spew on it we're very
restricted on what we're allowed to film
whenever we're on the move the rebels
keep hold of our camera we're not
allowed to show their faces Vladimir
tells us they're at war in his break the
former elite soldier watches Russian
television we asked him whether the
occupation of government buildings is
being supervised by Russia you look
closely I don't know in what way the
Russians are involved but i hope that
Russia will at least help us why because
the government in Kiev calls us bandits
and terrorists but I'm not a criminal
just because I'm fighting for my
political opinion bengi damn it we also
meet ordinary members of the public here
there's a canteen and even a hospital
ward which they're very happy to show us
dr. Najah sagar ova says they're
prepared for everything and could even
conduct operations she's been working
here right from the start of the
occupation listen I me what's duck
what's up I'm working free of charge
because we want independence
unfortunately Ukraine is no longer our
homeland the Ukrainian government treats
us very badly this country has no mother
only a stepmother they treat us like
dirt
dennis push Alan heads up the
self-declared Donetsk Republic on May
eleventh he plans to hold a public
referendum on independence for the
region at an improvised press conference
inside the building we asked him what
he'll do if the yes vote loses if the
majority decide they want to stay in a
unified Ukraine okay if they are not
afraid of being ruled by fascists then
there's nothing we can do we will clear
the building but right now that's hard
to imagine as we leave the building
members of the militia head off on their
next mission while we've been here the
separatists have just taken over another
television station